when I got whacked out of soprano yeah I
didn't watch it for a while yeah and
everybody kept cloners to see what's
going on since guys I won't watch it and
then I got caught up and I and I got
over that and you kept coming back it's
Reza's ghost but not as much as he
promised me who promised you David Chase
he says listen we're gonna get rid of it
you're gonna come back with any fat but
then he found that Rob robotic fish and
they said how did you find out you were
getting whacked just the script or did
they call you and be like this is a
great story what happened is after we
shot the pilot and they said we got
picked up then we knocked off 13
episodes and then they aired the 13
episodes and David went to France
because he made a lot of money he didn't
write the season 2 yet he comes back
it's all over the internet whisperer see
what happened to [ __ ] is [ __ ] a rat he
closing me up pieces you're up all over
the incident I didn't know what the
internet was he says so here's the deal
we're gonna go to the second season I'm
gonna write you're real strong you're
gonna be right we're gonna kill you okay
so he told you before yeah but you're
like that's not the greatest news in the
world because I had a seven-year
contract you think you've got a
permanent job
you know what the thing is though that's
you even though you're still one of the
most recognizable new shoes it didn't
matter like even though money-wise you
probably rather do more what Jimmy do
you think it's because of my nickname
big [ __ ] or you think it's because I
was a pretty good actor I was in truth
absolutely no it's both because big
[ __ ] such a unique name and you were
so good in it it was such a and you're
saying you believed him as a big person
yeah that's what made that show when
people and they [ __ ] killed you
people were like this show doesn't [ __ ]
around my life now I'm some tomato sauce
[Laughter]
call it big [ __ ] put the nasca sauce
right they said no what are you calling
it then I said what about big [ __ ]
marijuana sauce they said no so it's
Vinny pastors marinara sauce can you put
big [ __ ] on things like it or or what I
got a band let's go big [ __ ] Gangster
Squad has then as HBO or anybody gone
come after me fits all right I'm stupid
you know I me ask you something isn't
that join up we run around Ruby Tuesdays
with the wrong stone song Mick Jagger
trying to get any money out of that big
[ __ ] with somebody's name in Newark
real wise guy and I don't think they
have the trademark to big [ __ ] Yeah
right
how do you feel about the prequel that
they're making The Sopranos prequel oh
I've got pretty excited about it
I met the kid who played me he actually
had to come up to my house and hang out
with me for a while you should have done
things that were totally unlike you it's
just a [ __ ] him up for the role always
eating grapes you know he asked me he
asked me who lation LaRue was Richard
Pryor loved him he was a Western I only
know her because Harvey Keitel's line
and pulp fiction where he goes can you
keep your Spurs from jangling lash
Laroux yeah when they're getting rid of
the body
by the way I love the day I know there's
somebody out there listening that was on
board with ron funches and myself that
remember a very low tier WCW wrestler
from the late 90s lash Laroux news from
Louisiana that's what I had no idea I
was the guy on nitro John the guy from
the lovin Soprano card to get everybody
else I don't know there are a lot why
don't you get your own booth I'll take
care yeah I can't I know you need the
money see the money is awesome pitches
so you pitching tents DVD no I mean I
really would go to that and the guest
list there and go like I don't think
this person was even on this show
there's so many people here
it's pretty weird I think they're really
go to the bottom by the bowel and bring
in everybody they got all the the main
people but it day I think what they
wanted to do is just get as many people
in there that were on the show so you
said you were on the show no he was not
pitching tents in the film we did that
scene did you ever do a soprano episode
I did not unfortunately yes would you do
on The Sopranos
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]